ne partez pas sans moi laissez-moi vous
suivre
et
[Applaudissements]
tu connais pas les paroles alors si non
je déconne bien sûr que si et la Corée
et la alors ça j'ai pas j'étais pas là
quand il y a eu cours de Corée mais les
paroles bien sûr
moi j'ai jamais compris les horaires de
boulot on te dit toute seule de 8h à 18h
si tu es productif et que tu fais ton le
taf qu'on te demande de faire de ton
travail de de 10 heures à 15 ans mais
qu'il est mieux fait que si tu restes de
8 à 18 pourquoi mettre des horaires
infligées venons en fonction de notre
productivité il y a des gens qui mettent
trop de temps à travailler il y en a qui
sont plus efficaces
[Musique]
pour ceux parce que c'est important pour
la créativité
[Musique]
[Rires]
la discipline au Japon
le feu est rouge personne ne traverse
vous avez vu
et pourtant il n'y a pas une seule
voiture
il y a à droite et à gauche
non
moins de patiente pas une seule personne
traverse quand gribouille reste quelques
minutes dans sa chambre
[Musique]